welcome today we're checking out uh this
title big natty daddy he's only 15. very
curious let's watch
also you know if you're 15 you can't be
calling yourself daddy i don't care if
it rhymes that's the worst part of this
whole scenario
can't believe me
it increases the rate of protein
synthesis
which increases the rate that you can
build muscle it doesn't magically put
muscle on you it's still the exact same
process
as it would be if you were natural
that's really cool
like what do people actually believe
that taking steroids
you hit yourself
oh super strong now
like yeah you still have to work out i
think people know that much unless you
get one of these of course
fill yourself with voids get one of
these and instant six-pack baby
guaranteed that's a joke these are fake
these are don't buy these i made a joke
god damn it i like how i made a joke as
if something was obvious and then i had
to disclaim it just in case someone
doesn't get it
god damn it
bbc with that underground
they got the terms
oh my name is big daddy daddy it's just
about iron you know the natty part in
the middle of my name people are like oh
you're not natty people get mad about
that stuff when i clearly talk about you
know how i'm not natural
yeah don't you get it it's ironic
what
yeah i'm sorry you cannot play the irony
card when you're doing actual drugs
right
it's ironic you don't get it it's satire
oh man
uh bro this is sad i don't even know why
i'm laughing but um dude
this guy didn't even give the gym a
chance right he just walked in
all right first time at the gym who's
got the steroids let's go
let's get started he's talking about the
work he put in right how much work could
he have possibly put in at the age of
15. just to like you know kind of spark
controversy and things something that
people are going to talk about he's a
provocateur yes of course for
informational purposes this big natty
daddy guy when you're at that age you
don't really know what you want in your
life you have no idea
what you're doing to yourself and you
will regret this later on in life i'm
clearly not the average minded 15 year
old so i don't know why people keep
saying that
i don't know what i want out of life and
i'm stupid for just having fun enjoying
my life while it's here
my man hasn't even hit puberty yet
stupid i don't want to rip on this guy
he's clearly he's got he needs help
my dude you're hurting i don't know i
got to be honest i i don't know anything
about steroids so it doesn't really you
know i'm sure other people have
articulated better but you know when
you're 15 your body is
still developing
massively not just your body
but your mind as well so to be doing
drugs that heavily affect you that's
gonna have consequences for the rest of
your life
right and the side effects of steroids
you know are are not to play around with
i'm not complaining i like to hate but i
like the hate dude this guy's so foolish
this is a massive cope this whole video
i like the hate
all right
am i bullying this kid i don't mean to i
feel bad
big boy wait i'm a big boy i'm a big boy
daddy boy i'm a big boy people are mean
on instagram what do you mean
okay what are the comments big nipple
daddy no he's got out of all the things
he's got well proportioned nipples i
give him that and you will become skinny
again when you get off the juice off the
juice i guess yeah that's true
when really all it does is allow you to
take your physique to the next level you
still have to put in the work you still
have to go to the gym you still have to
eat six seven meals a day
i used to care about school i mean now
that i'm into this i don't really focus
too much on grades honestly what's the
point of grades if you're not getting
gains
come on i'm not the average minded 15
year old says every 15 year old everyday
i just don't think much of it i'm like i
got too much to do before i look the way
i want to look that's why i wear a
jacket sweatpants
even if i catch myself
and uh bruh okay and the reason why
you're wearing that hat literally in
every single shot is not at all that
you're showing symptoms of early balding
right that's just like he wears it in
every shot i'm sorry let's go through
the symptoms or the sorry the side
effects reduce sperm down infertility
great shrunken testicles nice erectile
dysfunction bubba boldness
breast development nice
you know i'm not here to make an
argument for or against steroid use i
you will just have to admit i don't know
enough about it i know i've heard people
say oh it's not as bad as drinking
alcohol
but even then you know too bad doesn't
make it right
yeah alcohol has problems too right and
oh and addiction is a whole other aspect
of it when you start when you're 15 i
mean my man he's balding 100
why is he running that hat right now
i think bodybuilding is about chasing a
perfect zeke that literally doesn't
exist it's kind of a self-induced
torture you know you'll never really be
able to find that perfect body
i've always been obsessed with the way
my body looks and the image of my body
and how other people see me especially
like when people take pictures of me or
something and i look bad i didn't like
that
man's got self-esteem issues holy [ __ ]
it's interesting he's admitting
that he's sort of self-aware about the
whole thing you know i will never reach
the right's physique and
you know i don't really care what people
do in general i think this is more
interesting because it's the actual
child but i think you know the reason i
would never do steroids is because i i
don't see the point that's just
what i think personally um if you lived
in a secluded world you would never find
use for steroids right unless you need
to get stronger for whatever reason
desperately there's no real reason to
justify doing steroids come on uh you
want to look better for other people and
you're not doing it for yourself because
if you wanted to just improve your
muscle you would just work out without
taking steroids you're doing steroids
because what you find you're gaining is
not enough which i understand it can be
frustrating trying to build muscles and
you're not doing it fast enough fine
there has to be some psychological play
here especially as an impressionable
young kid having muscles is often
associated with success
it's associated with getting women and
you're sort of sold this package it's
almost like uh
getting kids into these ideas of getting
rich quick oh you just gotta do steroids
sir you just gotta do this oh here we go
it's not wearing the hat it's too dark
to tell like i know 10 or 20 at my
school alone that have been using it and
i they don't look good you know they
look like average 15 year olds they're
strong sure i mean no matter what you do
if you're on you know like a pro hormone
or something like that you're gonna get
strong there's no way around that
other kids do steroids but they're not
as strong as i am so they're therefore
is it okay people ask me especially at
my age if they're if they should use it
i always tell them no it's not a good
idea to do it i know that like i'm fully
aware that it's not good
i like it though you know it's just what
i do it's just what i do no matter what
you do if you don't diet you don't train
ain't gonna get nowhere you can take all
the drugs in the world if you don't
stimulate the muscle if you don't feed
the muscles it's not gonna grow
simple as that
oh god i feel like he's talking down to
me it's very irritating listening to
this child it's harder
i've had this dream of looking good my
whole life it's never gone away so i
don't know what would make it go away
now especially oh dude hair loss i'm
actually making money um getting
attention and all that good stuff
all that good stuff but
that's where we differ instagram did
this kid dirty man you have a common
goal
that's why social media shouldn't be
allowed
for anyone over 18. i know i that would
make me out of a job i'll take it
fine but i will not return all the money
i made no he wants to do it on a
different approach
and
i can't say his approach is wrong i
can't say mine is wrong
i want to die young honestly
hopefully before 40 honestly which
sounds crazy people are like
four days when uh your muscle it's
harder to get gain muscle so of course
this guy wants to die when you're 40.
bro you're 15 you have no [ __ ] idea
if you let your mind develop you'll
actually get some different world views
right yeah i don't know what it takes
i'm 15 i know what it takes more than
y'all don't sleep
i'm sure someone who's who are high on
drugs feel happy in a moment if they
were gonna die but there's gonna be
consequences further on that are gonna
be heavier and that you're not gonna be
able to keep that same attitude that's
the whole point imagine injecting
steroids and still have small bites
cringe most athletes apparently do
service at least is being open about it
uh it is true it's way more prevalent
than you think i knew nothing about
steroids before working out i still
don't really get it uh but just finding
out especially in hollywood just how
common it is for actors they need to get
quick
rip for a role you know that's the best
method to do it is to use roids and
it's almost like the male version of
all these female models getting skinnier
and giving giving young girls you know
anorexia and all this stuff it's a male
equivalent of that with with the rip
guys in hollywood i feel like maybe i'm
over exaggerating i don't know the
actual effects of it but you know it
surely can't be healthy especially when
it's yeah it is kind of the same you
know how they even photoshop i mean i
don't know how if it's still as bad i'm
sounding like such a boomer my point is
with females models can be so skinny
that they even photoshop them skinny so
it's literally an unattainable standard
of beauty and for guys you know you have
to do
it take drugs to get this standard of i
don't know muscle weight or whatever if
you think that's cool
it's literally unattainable most people
don't even know that obviously our
subconsciousness don't always realize
but i think for guys most guys don't
even know that so many people do cerro
it's right at least he's not one of
those natty guys that tells everyone
that they are natural you know what i'll
give them that
[Laughter]
i'll give them that raw just be natty it
ain't worth it that's my sentiment thank
you for watching this video if you
thought it was interesting if you
enjoyed my subscribe for more videos see
you tomorrow with another one bye you
thought it was game
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this